they value
safety and dave the illusion of safety
more than they value uh personal liberty
and that's why uh they went along with
it i have very very many
intelligent friends who just couldn't
wait to put that mask on
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
former new jersey superior court judge
and host of the judging freedom podcast
judge andrew napolitano welcome to the
reuben report a pleasure to be on with
you dave thank you for having me i'm
glad to have you before we dive into the
to the issues of the day and there's a
lot of stuff sort of culturally
politically but especially legally that
i want to talk to you about uh there's a
rumor
that you might be up on a farm somewhere
in the middle of nowhere and i find that
to be interesting considering most
people picture you with a suit slick
back hair some makeup but but you like
living on a farm huh well uh for 24
years i was very happy at fox news they
put me in front of a camera you ready
for this
14
500 times
and they have the clothes police there
really wonderful people but make sure
you were dressed properly and the makeup
was right in your hair was right
uh since uh covid and then after i left
uh fox i've been doing everything from
my farm which is at the north where i am
now which is at the northwest tip of new
jersey where new york new jersey and
pennsylvania meet we average about 15
degrees colder than new york city so
i've left here in a blizzard and got to
manhattan and it's just rain we're we're
about 1800 feet above sea level
and what are you doing up on a farm i
mean are you out there are you are you
you know pulling up uh vegetables and
you got
there what are you doing
i signed the checks the wonderful guys
that work for me get dirty fingernails
uh we just finished making maple syrup
we grow we have an apple orchard and a
pear orchard uh and we grow um about
500 pounds of garlic
and we grow a lot of green vegetables
our our clients are
hotels and restaurants uh in the area
it's a lot of fun it's uh
given me an appreciation for the
environment that i never had before i
had this this property yeah very cool i
just thought it was worth mentioning up
top because i think when people see
people especially on cable news there's
something about
seeing the person in the box where you
don't realize that they're actually a
person too that they just appear to be
this head floating with a friend like
you i'm very much a person
you are very much a person all right
well let's do a little bit of the of the
person uh so former superior court judge
in jersey um what what got you
interested in the law in the first place
how does someone end up as a judge
people think of law you're going to
become a lawyer how did you end up as a
judge in the first place well i ended up
as a lawyer because
at dinner table conversations i always
took the side of the underdog much to my
parents dismay
uh i loved debating in high school and
even in college so i i went to princeton
one of my classmates sam alito one of my
boyhood friends is now on the supreme
court of the united states
new jersey's uh system is a little
different than other states
you practice law for 10 years and then
after that are eligible to be appointed
i was the youngest person
appointed in the history of the state i
was actually appointed before i had
completed that 10-year mark but it
didn't take office until after i
completed it appointed by the governor
confirmed by the state senate for seven
years
if reappointed and reconfirmed before
the end of seven you have it for life
so i was appointed by a wonderful
moderate republican governor tom kane
and then seven years later received my
lifetime appointment by another
wonderful moderate republican
governor christine todd whitman at the
trial level
where i was where there are 400 judges
in the state
there are roughly 200 republicans and
200 democrats so it's not it's not
political because it's not a policy
making court you're trying cases you're
deciding who you believe you're not
making decisions like the supreme court
of the united states does
how did you make sure that your politics
didn't
leak into it i mean i have a sense from
watching you over the years of what your
politics are but i know you you try to
be as on your show you try to be as
non-partisan as possible but obviously
people have their own biases have their
own ways of looking at the world how did
you do it and do you think do you think
that enough judges are doing it these
days because it does seem these days
that courts seem to be slanted wonder
one way or another well i i like you
believe that our rights are natural and
come from our humanity
whether you believe in god as i do and
that it's a gift from god or whatever
you believe we have developed these
rights by our own exercise of reason
they don't come from the government
they're not they're not privileges
they're not licenses their rights their
claims
and and therefore i believe that the
constitution literally means what it
says
if the government wants to take life
liberty or property it has to follow due
process
uh if which means a jury trial at which
the government proves fault it doesn't
mean an edict thou shalt wear a mask
thou shalt take a vaccine thou shalt not
stand closer than six feet from the next
person thou shalt not open your
restaurant business all of those in my
view are unconstitutional unlawful and
immoral because they violate your
uh your natural rights
does that seep into the judicial process
yes it does
uh before a criminal trial
the government must demonstrate to the
court how it acquired the evidence in
the case
because the supreme court of the united
states and the supreme court of new
jersey have both ruled if the evidence
was obtained unlawfully that as if the
police broke the law when they're
ostensibly enforcing the law then the
evidence can't be introduced at trial
if you are a
natural law libertarian as i am
uh you tend to to to follow that to a t
translated i probably suppressed more
evidence than all the other judges in
the courthouse combined so i was not the
prosecutor's favorite except on
sentencings then they loved me because
there's a wing of the new jersey state
prison with my name on it because i sent
so many bad violent people there not
people who committed harmless crimes but
people who committed real crimes so yes
it's more
a philosophy than a politics
that filters into
the the judging
process
do you have ever said that much of it is
mechanical you're trying a case you want
to make sure the jury understands you
want to make sure both sides get a fair
shake even in sentencing you know i'm
talking about jesse smallette three or
four times uh this week had an unusual
twist the other day when the appellate
court let him out for the reason for
which they let him out but when judges
sentenced dave they have a checklist 25
aggravating factors 25 mitigating
factors so you're not shooting from your
hip you're deciding do the aggravating
factors outweigh the mitigating factors
is this a human being who really is a
danger to society and needs to be locked
up
or is this somebody who just got carried
away got involved in something and it
got out of control and he didn't have
the courage to admit uh that it was
wrong you have to make those
objective and subjective judgments
before you take someone's freedom away
so so i want to get more to smile in
just a minute but i i find that really
interesting about so you really tried to
keep the the law of the letter regarding
policing and if they broke the law okay
the evidence can't be submitted were
there times i'm sure there were that you
saw something that was so damning so
incriminating and you're going man if i
don't let this be submitted there's a
really bad dude who's about to walk and
yet you'd still have to do it
yes
yes you do and i you know talk to police
about this police who have
beaten confessions out of people or or
cracked a taillight after they stopped
the car because they got a tip that
drugs were in the trunk and they needed
a lawful
basis for smashing the taillight i said
to one of them i said you know you and i
grew up in the same neighborhood
i didn't come down with yesterday's rain
you know i was gonna see through this
and he said yes here's how we look at it
we got this stuff off the street
we know a guilty guy went went free and
he's probably going to do it again and
we'll get him the next time and the next
time we'll follow the law but we just
took 10 pounds of cocaine off the street
our problem was that we got assigned to
you because you're the only judge in the
courthouse that would have caught us for
doing this
so you know there are factors to weigh
but my oath is to the constitution
when i was on the bench
it's not to the government it's not to
the prosecutors it's not to the police
it's to the constitution it's the
constitution that mandates that uh
illegally obtained evidence can't be
used in a trial in america if it could
there would be no trials everybody would
plead guilty because the police would
beat the crap out of everybody
so i want to get to uh the issues of the
day and we'll talk about smilet and the
supreme court justice nominee and all
that stuff but so what possessed you
to go from the the court which you
obviously loved it's very obvious
hearing you talk about it to saying hey
i'll i'll do this on television which is
a whole other game
well
i'm a little embarrassed to tell you
except this public knowledge because i
said it at the time
i was tired of being poor
[Laughter]
so judges at the time made a hundred
thousand dollars a year with zero
outside income in addition to being a
judge i was a full-time law professor
but teaching just at night so it didn't
interfere with my
judicial duties i was also lecturing
around the country about the types of
things that we're talking about human
liberty and natural rights and one day
one of my clerks a very bright
person said to me
do you know if you could charge the fair
market value for this stuff you do at
night it will be two and a half times
what the state is paying you for what
you do during the day
ah
that was it i didn't i didn't leave the
bench
to go on television i left the bench to
go back into the pits
and try cases
um
eight or nine years before i had met
roger ailes
at the kansas city
uh republican national convention in
1976
ronald reagan versus gerald ford
roger was the chief strategist for one
of the two camps i'll let you guess
which camp it was
when i say
almost everybody says reagan he was on
ford's side no why well that's why i
paused because i thought you were
setting me up for a trap there right
ford was the president of the united
states anyway that's where i met uh
roger rails uh i left the bench the
statement about being poor
had such legs it was all over the place
life-tenured judge leaves because of you
know
poor salaries and you can't earn outside
income and people dumped on me what do
you mean a hundred thousand dollars is
poor that's more than 90 percent of the
country makes blah blah blah blah blah
roger ailes read about it
o.j simpson had just been indicted
ailes was then the president of cnbc
he said we're going to cover this
and i'm going to put my own ex-judge on
air to second-guess this crazy loopy
judge edo
so for five days a week with my
future colleague at fox john gibson
we covered o.j john in the courtroom and
interviewing people outside the
courthouse and me providing analysis for
cnbc at their offices in englewood
cliffs new jersey
then um microsoft and nbc formed
msnbc roger did not get the presidency
of it probably the worst mistake nbc
ever made
he left
form fox and brought those of us who had
worked for him at cnbc over to fox
basically said i don't know where it's
going to go it's a gamble we could all
be bankrupt in a week
now that was 25 26 years ago
and do did you feel covering
from oj to to all the stuff that you
were covering on fox for you know 15 20
years uh actually more uh did you feel
that there is a risk in doing some of
that day-to-day on on cable news that
you have to be more sensational or that
you maybe aren't privy to all the
information that's going on in the
courtroom or you got to keep people
watching and know you know one of the
things that i find tough when you when
you follow court cases these days the
way everyone seems to do on cable news
we're suddenly privy to all of this
information that maybe we all shouldn't
be privy to all the time or at least the
public shouldn't care about every little
in and out of every little thing how do
you try to blend that i agree with you
that the public shouldn't care about
every little in and out and and every
little thing but in this era of cable
news
we do i don't know how the founding
fathers would have fared if cable news
had been around not well not well
um
you know fox had and has terrific
researchers
they also allowed me to hire my own
researcher a lawyer
uh in between fox's researchers known
affectionately as the brain room
and my researcher i i was able to um
to devour what i needed to know
occasionally you make a mistake
sometimes the mistake leads uh to a
lawsuit but remember you're explaining
things
for the public you're not making an
argument before the supreme court so you
don't
you don't need to know everything the
key is to explain it so that the public
understands it appreciates the
explanation and wants more of it
okay so with that in mind let let's
switch to some of the issues of the day
so you brought up the jesse smellette
thing which we covered a whole bunch
over the last few weeks
so he gets sentenced ever there's really
no one other than him i suppose and his
lawyer who's claiming that he's still
innocent i mean it's it's sort of
bananas and everyone saw the diatribe at
the end during the sentencing uh he gets
the 150 days in jail and a couple other
things but basically he's going to serve
a week in jail and that's it they're
going to let him out
what do you make of
the sentencing
then the shortening of the sentencing
and just the media part of this and and
how do you think the judge had to deal
with the media portion of it okay the
media is not easy to deal with in the
era that i was on the bench dave cameras
were not permitted
in courtrooms and in the few courtrooms
in which they were permitted the judge
had an absolute right to exclude them
today you can't exclude them in federal
court they're not permitted but in state
courts they're there all the time
they're tiny uh they don't make any
noise after a while you forget that
they're there but they are there which
is why we all know more detail than we
need to know
uh i thought his sentencing was fair
normally
lying to the police does not implicate
jail time
i have a problem with punishing people
for lying to the police or lying to the
fbi because
the law allows the fbi and the police to
lie to you
so if they can lie do you remember the
martha stewart case they lied to her in
the same conversation in which she lied
to them the fbi agent who lied to her
got a promotion she went to jail for six
months for lying to them so wait a
little
quick sidebar on that i was a pa on
martha stewart's talk show when she came
back after jail time and she still had
the monitor on her foot when she was
doing the show
when she came to fox she asked for me
and hugged and kissed me
we are we are from two towns next to
each other bloomfield new jersey and
nutley new jersey bloomfield very
italian at the time
polish her name is no more stewart than
minus smith but she
she promoted that very uh very well now
back to uh jesse
because the lies were regular consistent
systematic and because the government
wasted
125 to 150 000 investigating the lies i
believe that the jail sentence of 150
days
and the restitution to the government
was appropriate now his sentence was not
shortened he was let off on appeal
it's an interesting reason why i was led
off on appeal because if he started
serving 150 days immediately he would be
finished with it before the appeal would
ever even be heard because it takes a
year or two for the appellate courts to
hear your appeal because the appeals get
online on the basis of when they were
filed
so he's still facing 150 days
in jail unless the appellate court
decides either that he was wrongfully
convicted
or that he was uh over punished i don't
think either is the case
right
in a situation like that so when they
finally get to it do they usually just
say ah we're sort of past this thing and
just let them go at this point
well no because the prosecutors will be
pounding the table the the the appellate
court would have to find
that the trial was unfair the trial
judge made mistakes of such a magnitude
uh that he was not proven guilty or that
the sentence was unfair the sentence was
not unfair was well within the range
that the statute allowed so his only
hope
uh is to find that because the first
prosecutor said i'm not going to
prosecute you they shouldn't have
assigned it to a second prosecutor
that's his only hope uh on appeal that
once a prosecutor said we're not
prosecuting you
uh
that that was it
most states once a prosecutor says we're
not going to prosecute you they don't
send it to another prosecutor they did
it
because jesse
became very very unpopular
uh in the chicago community now you
shouldn't be prosecuted just because
you're unpopular you should be
prosecuted if there's enough evidence to
convict and if your behavior has caused
harm
where does that
that if your behavior has caused harm
where does that go when it comes to the
prosecuting meaning that
in terms of the actual crime he
committed
you know to set up this hoax there's not
a lot of damage done but i think you
could argue that there was a tremendous
amount of damage done to society to the
city of chicago but the whole country in
terms of this culture war that we're
fighting how often do you think judges
are affected by that that there's a much
bigger fight at play than the specifics
of oh okay he paid these two guys he
made up this thing that we could kind of
look past but it's really that you could
argue that then there were more riots
because of this or just the general
flame of the culture war continues
because of something like this so that
cannot be taken into account at the time
of sentencing but here's something that
can be that i think will interest you
and the folks listening to us now
when i told you there's a checklist 25
aggravating and 25 mitigating factors
one of the aggravating factors is
the defendant committed this crime as a
cost of doing of doing business
now that was put in there because of
mafia guys who committed crimes as a
cost of doing business
and the judge in my opinion quite
properly did check that box jesse
concocted this whole thing
as a cost of doing business now
he and i ultimately had the same bosses
because we both worked for fox
he's crazy to think that he's going to
get a leg up but fox
in this nonsense maybe he had another
network but not at fox they'd be sorry
that it happened but that's not going to
uh not going to help uh the careers
but back to your question the only harm
was to the government
the only harm traceable to his behavior
was a hundred and fifty thousand dollars
in police overtime investigating an
event that never occurred
now he was charged with six lies because
they interrogated him six times
and each time he gave them the same
nonsensical story he was convicted of
five we won't know why without asking
the jurors
the the sixth one that did not result in
a conviction each of those uh could have
been three years in jail he ended up
with a 150 days
all right so let's let's shift to a
couple of the other things going on
right now so obviously uh joe biden has
selected katanji brown jackson to be his
nominee for the supreme court
i have no doubt that this once the the
hearings begin will be as chaotic as
ever maybe not quite as chaotic as brett
kavanaugh because she's kind of on the
side of the media but you know the usual
stuff is gonna happen um i guess a
uh what would your general
qualifications be i think i have a sense
of that already and b how do we pilfer
some truth out of this knowing that the
media is not going to cover it the way
it would
if say she was nominated by donald trump
or a republican president
i start with the premise that under the
constitution the president gets to
nominate whoever he wants and believe it
or not dave
neither the constitution nor federal law
require that a supreme court justice
even be a lawyer
much less uh
held prior judicial experience
the last justice who didn't even
graduate from law school was justice
robert jackson who had been the attorney
general of the united states under fdr
and he's one of the most quotable
justices
in the modern era never graduated from
law school today of course
the senate would not confirm anyone who
didn't graduate from law school
uh the senate and the presidents seem to
prefer
people who have judicial experience
that's not required uh at all
uh chief justice earl warren
had no judicial experience and probably
uh affected
uh jurisprudence in this country more
than anybody chief justice john marshall
the great chief justice
from the thomas jefferson to the andrew
jackson years he had no
judicial experience
and because joe biden nominated her
she's a liberal democrat that's to be
expected donald trump i'm very familiar
with his nomination process since i was
intimately involved the first time
around
donald trump in my opinion
nominated two conservatives and one
libertarian libertarian is neil gorsuch
uh the conservatives are amy coney
barrett as a graduate of the same law
school as i am university of notre dame
uh and uh and brett kavanaugh that's the
president's
uh prerogative i don't agree with
senator lindsey graham and many things
but i agree with him on this the
president nominated the person and he or
she is basically qualified i'm going to
vote for them
i think that's what the outcome will be
with judge katanchi brown jackson
however
there are a conservative republicans on
the judiciary committee and i know them
both well ted cruz has been a friend of
mine for years
josh hawley i we have met through the
monitor like you and i are meeting now
they're going to go for her jugular
they're going to find
decisions that she made which she
believes she was compelled to make under
the law which appear inexplicable
to the public
not to hurt her not to deny her the the
job because she'll certainly get it but
to embarrass the president
this uh you know this started with
robert bork
and it was joe biden i started here with
clarence thomas
um and then of course
brett kavanaugh it doesn't happen to all
of them it didn't happen amy coney
barrett it did not happen to ruth bader
ginsburg it did not happen to neil
gorsuch but every once in a while there
is a nominee
that the minority party that's the party
that's not in the white house
thinks they can tarnish
the person who did the nomination by
tarnishing
the candidate history has shown
that does not carry over into the
nominees judicial opinions
whatever you think of of clarence thomas
he is either forgiven or forgotten and
the same thing with
uh with brett kavanaugh robert of work
of course the trashing worked uh he was
rejected by a vote of 52 against and 48
in favor
yeah which joe biden basically led the
charge on do you think that there's some
do you think that there's some value in
say ted cruz josh hawley some of these
other guys
going for the jugular even if she's
going to be confirmed either way just to
to at least expose some of the thinking
behind the decisions so that people can
frame the issues properly even if they
can't stop it even though and of course
it becomes a certain way so the
political i think the values to the
political base yeah most respectfully to
my friends
uh for uh ted cruz uh and uh josh hawley
i don't think there's any value
to the public
in having a circuit court judge explain
the intricacies of a judicial opinion
which really only law school graduates
uh can comprehend
a lot of times i made decisions on the
bench that the law forced me to make
that i sent people to jail
for crimes that in my opinion were
victimless and shouldn't have been
crimes and they should not have gone to
jail like the
three strikes on possession of marijuana
he went away for 20 years that's so
absurd especially today where it's legal
in 37 states but there are times when
judges must do things that they don't
want to do because they've taken an oath
to uphold the law and the law requires
it
explaining that
so that the public can understand it is
a very
difficult task
what about if the judge was truly
radical and i i honestly don't know
enough about her her full resume and
obviously we're going to hear it but
what if they were someone that really
did not hold any of the principles that
you mentioned at the beginning about our
founding documents and individual rights
and they really were activists in terms
of they wanted to fundamentally change
the way the the country is run you'd
you'd want some exploratory version of
it right the answer is yes however with
uh with judge jackson i mean she was
confirmed to the united states district
court eight years ago and then was
confirmed by this very same senate
to the circuit court of appeals
one year ago
so they've already gone through all this
however if if
if some
nominee did not believe that the
constitution was the supreme law of the
land
or believed that the declaration of
independence was just jefferson's
musings
or that the first amendment really
doesn't guarantee the freedom of speech
that person would probably be
disqualified and those views should be
exposed
all right so let's move on to uh to
russia because you've taken the position
uh that i i fully respect because it's
hard to get any
sort of sense out of what's going on
with russia and ukraine that that
sanctions
actually violate the constitution so can
you explain that a bit
sure
and this is not anti anti-joe biden i
honestly believe he's doing everything
he can
short of war
to resist putin
i also believe that putin's ultimately
going to win and that by our arming the
ukrainians were probably making it worse
bloodier and more deadly
however however
the sanctions fall into three categories
seizing assets
freezing uh assets
and interfering with contracts
so under the fourth amendment if the
government freezes a bank account
they've reached your bank account for
example you can't take any money out
that's a seizure
and under the fourth amendment the
government can only seize something with
a search warrant
after they demonstrate to a judge like i
was assigned hundreds of these
uh probable cause of crime
so if they seize your yacht in the bay
of naples if the carabinieri which is
the italian version of the fbi sees as
your yacht in the bay of naples and they
won't let you on it and they've
sent it to port newark so that the feds
can actually
own it and sell it
they have seized your property illegally
if they've frozen your bank account
without a search warrant they are frozen
your bank account illegally
if they have interfered with lawful
commercial transactions if for example
you're an importer of stolich naya vodka
and you've paid for a cargo ship full of
stolich naya and it arrives at port
newark or chicago or detroit and the
feds send it away
well then the the feds have interfered
with your lawful commercial transactions
the fifth amendment says if the
government wants life liberty
contractual rights or property income
from the contract they have to have a
jury trial at which fault is proven now
under what basis is president biden
engaging in these sanctions there's two
statutes dave
that the feds enacted one is the
international economic emergency act of
1977
carter era
one is the magnitsky act of 2016
obama era both of these statutes allow
the president
without any evidence or judicial process
whatsoever to declare a human being or
an entity foreign human being or foreign
entity
a violator of human rights
and seize their assets
and if they want the assets back if
you're this billionaire whose yacht was
stolen
by the carabinieri and you want it back
you have to come to america
submit to the federal court jurisdiction
which they're never going to do because
they're afraid they'll get arrested for
some trumped-up charge and then you have
to prove that you're not
a human rights violator how do you prove
a negative
and that's alice in wonderland you're in
a federal court the government wants
your property and you have to prove that
you're not what they say you are forget
about it the government has the burden
of proof the person whose life liberty
or property the government wants always
is presumed
innocent and to presume to be the valid
owner of the life liberty or property
so this these two statutes which have
not been challenged constitutionally
because these foreigners are not going
to come here to challenge them
give the president dictatorial powers
which he has exercised
why do you think some of our companies
maybe that do business with russia say
i'll use the example that you gave i
mean you're just an american company
who's a vodka importer who's now your
business in essence has been destroyed i
mean should they be suing the federal
government at this point yes they should
yeah
yes they yeah they should
look the government
i don't know what you think of this
phrase the government loves to hate
i like it
okay so for mostly 200 years government
hated black people either as slaves or
under jim crow
the federal government told us to hate
the soviet union and then hate iran and
then hate iraq and then hate saddam
hussein and then pardon this hate
covered now it's hate putin and hate all
things russian well the russian people
have nothing to do with this they have
the misfortune of being being
uh governed by a uh a dictator i don't
think he's crazy i think he's perfectly
rational but he doesn't care about human
liberty or about human life and innocent
people are are being punished
are being harmed the the ruble buys
about five percent today
of what it bought a month ago so you're
paying 15
for a loaf of bread that should have
cost a dollar fifty
yeah absolutely incredible i hope some
of these companies fight that i mean
because that's where people forget these
we're now punishing americans these are
these are americans who just happen to
do business with something that perhaps
originated in russia let's move to kovid
because you've hit it a couple of times
here i mean
i'm pretty sure that anything you're
going to say on the coveted front i
agree with you i think our civil
liberties have been destroyed as you
know i fled california just in the last
couple months i now live in the free
state of florida because i could not
deal with the lockdowns and the mass
mandates and the general state of
depression that it brought and all of
the closed businesses and the dreams
that were shattered and the whole
freaking thing however we've still got
masks on planes uh they've still got
masks on you know three-year-olds in in
you know toddlers yet joe biden can give
the state of the union with a bunch of
80 year olds in a room with no windows
and that's okay
what do you make of the entire
freaking thing was this just a disaster
from you know we're basically at the two
year anniversary two years ago
should we have been all screaming louder
and known what was coming okay so you're
you're you're scratching at the surface
of what my biggest complaint and fear is
i am not surprised that the government
exercised the dictatorial powers
because the the government doesn't care
about human liberty it just cares about
power and staying in power and if the
government can give the impression that
it's doing something it will stay in
power what has crushed me and broken my
heart
is how americans accepted this
how we laid down and allowed them to
close churches
to close school as well the government
owns the schools but to interfere with
freedom of travel with freedom of
assembly
even with freedom of speech i mean not
far from where i am now in this
beautiful a countryfied area on palm
sunday two palm sundays ago
a catholic priest was distributing palms
wrapped in cellophane
outdoors to people in their cars
and the state police broke it up
the cars were too close to each other
and they were too close to this priest
as he physically handed them the palms
wrapped in cellophane and i went uh
berserk on air and
in in my writings because the governor
who ordered this
appeared at a black lives matter uh
rallying a they're part of the black
lives matter that i think is absolutely
legitimate there were three thousand
people there they weren't masked and he
was the featured speaker
so this is an example of the government
using
power to promote its own power and the
american public accepted it
i once had an argument with roger ailes
about whether
a dictator could ever take over in the
united states and he took the position
it wouldn't that the public would never
stand for it
well when the public is afraid the
government's weapon was fear
we became a nation of sheep
and we still are
because governor murphy of new jersey
governor whitmer of michigan former
governor cuomo of new york that
mentality could come back in a week if
some unnamed variant of covid kicks in
again
people just don't learn huh i mean i'm
not completely
back they will bring it back and people
will do the exact same thing and they
will say thank you sir may i have
another yes and they value
safety and dave the illusion of safety
more than they value uh personal liberty
and that's why uh they went along with
it i have very very many
intelligent friends who just couldn't
wait to put that mask on
what do you make of the way we began to
worship well not we but many people in
the country began to worship
these agencies say the cdc or the nih
these are unelected people there some of
them are appointed people but they're
unelected people who we basically
outsourced our public policy to in terms
of who you could stand next to and what
restaurant could be open and everything
else and also that nobody gets fired i
mean that if i was to take away one
thing from this that how how has nobody
at the cdc been fired nobody two weeks
to flatten the curve it's two years
later nobody was fired anywhere david
nobody electing people for policy would
they get installed and then they just
exist nobody was fired in the uh in the
intelligence community after 9 11.
people don't get fired no matter what
the calamity is in part because the
government has enacted statutes that
insulate itself from liability
when it drops the ball and people get
hurt one of my least favorite presidents
i'm a graduate of princeton university
he was the president of princeton and
then the governor of new jersey and then
president united states woodrow wilson
princeton has since stripped his name
from everything there when i was there
half the place was named wilson this and
wilson that
created the administrative state
this constitutional law professor said
we should be governed by people smarter
than we are
now he might not have envisioned the cdc
but he's the one that started the ball
rolling now there are 30 or 40
of these three and four letter acronym
government entities
the membership on which doesn't change
no matter who's in the white house or
who what party controls congress they
have more control over our lives than uh
than the congress does the only person
the only president in the modern era
that thumbed his nose at this whole
thing and tried to suppress it was
donald trump
and and parts of it the intelligence and
law enforcement community went right
back at him and we all know what
happened
what should we do i mean is is there any
legal recourse that i've been trying to
discuss this on my show the last couple
weeks that you know as we're somewhat
out of the fog of covet although i do
believe somehow magically it will
reappear that we can't forget all of the
people that put us in this position now
no we're not on the side of gulags and
jailing people and all that but do you
think there is any recourse
for public officials who demanded
clearly unconstitutional mandates
related to vaccines that now they're
pulling back because they finally
realized it wasn't working i mean is
there anything within the legal system
not not to blow up the legal system to
jail them but is there anything legally
that we could be doing to so that some
of these people that there's some
repercussion otherwise we will do it all
again the short and regrettable answer
is no
for the reason we talked about a few
minutes ago the government has insulated
itself
from the consequences of its own
misbehavior could could i sue
phil murphy the governor of new jersey
because he closed the catholic church or
all churches in in new jersey and i
wasn't able to receive the blessed
sacrament on easter no i cannot
so the answer is either political you
you couldn't sue for violation of the
fourth amendment i mean violation of uh
you know right to assembly
i mean is there
you know the the constitution has a
clause that requires standing
and standing means that you have an
injury
uh distinct from all others so if the
injury afflicts everybody the remedy is
political the courts are not going to
hear it if he denied
just dave rubin's right to go to a
restaurant or just just judge
napolitano's right
to go to our lady queen of peace on
easter sunday
you'd have the right to sue and i'd have
the right to sue but because gavin
newsom denied i think you were in
california at the time everybody's right
and because phil murphy denied
everybody's right the courts will say
the remedy is political you don't like
them throw them out of office so the
remedy is either political or radical
the radical remedy
is to do how the country began
cc'd
we seceded from great britain
i wouldn't be surprised maybe not in my
lifetime but perhaps yours if the
federal government can't pay its bills
its money becomes worthless and the
country breaks apart
into a dozen smaller countries where you
are will be the land of the free where
texas is will be the land of the free
where i am in the northeast it'll be the
people's republic
wow judge i did not know you were going
to go there but this is a theory i've
been teasing out a little bit on my show
i'm kind of there there's a bunch of
writers talking about this i'm not i
don't like the idea of secession and i
like the idea of the united states but
to me the federal government is so out
of control for all the reasons you've
just described i don't think it can be
repaired i can tell you and i think i've
been in california my guys have a
counter 91 days right now i've been in
florida and since i left i feel like i
live in a different country and the
problem is that in the free states
they're not going to want anything
nobody in florida wants anything from
the people in california but the people
in california want something from the
people in florida that that's an
untenable position
you know the government the federal
government fears two things
it fears loss of power over certain
geographical areas so if florida secedes
feds couldn't control florida at all and
it fears
tax it fears loss of tax dollars
if everybody who lives in florida didn't
have to pay a federal income tax the
feds would be pulling their hair out
because of the same thing what happened
in texas and montana and uh and other
states and this this behemoth that we've
allowed to grow
from woodrow wilson to joe biden and
republicans are just as bad just as bad
you know george bush borrowed three
trillion donald trump trump borrowed 2
trillion joe biden borrowed 1 trillion
in just one year
that we've allowed this monstrosity
to get out of control to mortgage the
future to sap our liberties
uh the only way around it would be
to let it go by the wayside
well then i have to ask you what keeps
you in the northeast what's keeping you
in jersey with the high taxes and
everything else i mean this is right i
love my farm i love this property i love
i love the real estate
you are not the only friend uh that asks
me that almost all of them do but you
are one of the happiest people i know
i'm telling you man i'm a lot happier
now than i was two months ago you know
fox sent me to california for a year
to do a reality show i played myself
it's called power of attorney it was a
judge judy like show we had celebrity
lawyers so the oj case had just ended we
had all the lawyers from o.j the late
great athlete bailly and i became great
friends from this show you know they
were half hour shows
superstar lawyers the typical case was
the dry cleaner i ruined my dress but he
also tried to pick up my sister you know
it was
it was nonsense like that
i hated it i hated all that time in
california i couldn't wait to come home
and that's why it was still open i mean
geez
uh okay i want to cover one one more big
one for you uh which i'm covering pretty
much every day here and it frames almost
everything i do which is some of the big
tech stuff and and where the law should
be involved and where it should not and
how that relates to free speech uh do
you view these these platforms facebook
twitter etc as sort of the new public
square and if they squelch a person or a
story obviously in the last week we now
know that the hunter biden laptop story
is legit and yet facebook and twitter
not only banned the story from being
post but literally shut down the new
york post's twitter account um what are
there some legal remedies here or is
this just left to congressional hearings
that nothing ever happens for the
reasons that you've been laying out this
whole time
in my opinion it should be left to the
free market
you know facebook in my view is just a
glorified uh high-tech bulletin board
they own the bulletin board and if they
don't like something that was posted
they can take it down i don't like it
i've been criticized uh by them but
their private entity the last thing in
the world we want is a federal
government involved in speech because
the government will favor the speech of
its its benefactors and it will favor
the speech it likes and disfavor the
speech that is critical of it the free
market in ideas as well as the free
market in electronic bulletin boards if
you'll pardon that phrase
is what should resolve this so someone
like charles koch
should start his own facebook and you'll
watch mark zuckerberg's profits go way
down as hundreds of millions of people
migrate over to another uh bulletin
board
hint hint i suppose that charles koch
intent i know him well and he's
he's turned down this idea but i keep
pushing it
judge i've thoroughly enjoyed this i i
hope you'll come back and uh
good luck in jersey man listen if if the
country does split
i've got a guest room
you're very kind uh it's a pleasure to
be on with you i've admired your work
for years and i'd love to do it again
thank you dave maybe you'll come on
judging freedom with me i think i'm
coming on in a couple weeks that's what
they're telling me i think so great if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversation about law
instead of the non-stop yelling you get
everywhere else check out our law
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell